as someone who used to run things behind
the scene what you make of what we're
witnessing in and around whitehall at
the moment
it's pretty unprecedented i think in in
two ways
the first is that normally when a
government gets into trouble it's
because it's doing something that is
either very unpopular with your viewers
or it's doing something that is
unpopular internally with its party
whereas the problems the current
government have got are all about the
prime minister's behavior essentially
they're not about policy
uh issue
and then i think the second way in which
it's unprecedented is
both you know i as a former politician
and you as a journalist i think we would
probably agree
that whenever a government has a
difficult story the best way to handle
it is to get all the facts out there as
quickly as possible and and be contrite
whereas
the handling of this story has said the
truth has been dragged out of number 10
day by painful day over about six months
yeah
just in terms of of what we saw clearly
in terms of the strategy the government
is suffering on the big picture stuff
you know
there is a degree of truth to the fact
that actually there is an awful lot for
the government to be doing right now and
there is an awful lot of focus on
everything else but just look at the way
in which the amendment and the motion
yesterday this
once again the conservative government
doesn't appear to to know the mood of
its own back benches
yeah i think yesterday was it was a
hugely significant day in two regards
the first as you say
is that the whips clearly believed they
could get the conservative mps to vote
for this amendment and discover that
they couldn't so that tells us that the
mood among conservative mps isn't quite
as supportive of the pm as maybe uh some
people were having us believe two or
three days ago and secondly i think
steve baker's intervention yesterday
is very significant you know steve was a
key person
uh in terms of teresa's downfall
he is not someone i agree with
ideologically but he is a highly
principled person and he's also
a very effective operator so if i was
still doing my old job in number 10 i
would be very worried about that
intervention yesterday
so just in terms of the mood within the
conservative parliamentary party at the
moment i mean do you detect from the
conversations that you will i'm sure be
having uh with colleagues said you're in
the comments do you detect the death
rattle for boris johnson's time as prime
minister i mean on so many occasions up
until now people have predicted his
demise and he has
and he has stayed firmly put
i don't think we're there yet
i think what i would say is that there
is severe discomfort at what the prime
minister has done and mp's having to
defend it
the thing that is the two things that i
think are keeping him in place at the
moment if this had happened
two or three months ago before the
conflict in ukraine
and before the problems that rishi sunak
has got into then i think definitely
that would have been the end so that the
two things that are
allowing people like conor to mount a
defense of the prime minister are don't
change right now given what's going on
in the world
and the lack of a clear obvious
that mps could switch to but you know i
think this story's got a way to play yet
with i suspect the prime minister is
going to receive more fines because
actually the the birthday party event
was probably the least egregious
of the breaches that we've read about
we're going to get the sue grey report
now we've got this privileges committee
investigation so
and my own view has been very clear for
a while that the prime minister should
go on because i think what he's done is
indefensible and i don't think it's in
the interest of the conservative party
for him to stay
but not all mps are at that point yet i
suspect this has got a way to go still
how concerned then should the party's
strategist be
about the may local elections i mean i
saw some speculation this morning it
could be as high as 800 seats lost
across the board but you always have to
bear in mind the conservatives have been
in government since 2010
the government tends to lose seats with
local elections i mean it's possible
they can spin their way out of this one
yes i think it depends how bad the
results turn out to be you you would ex
let's be honest
we've got a we've got a cost of living
crisis going on at the moment which is
not
uh ultimately caused by the government
it's a it's a global economic situation
that every advanced economy is facing
but understandably voters are concerned
and angry about that and feeling that
the government hasn't done enough to
support them
uh and then you've got this particular
issue on top of that so
the the thing that conservatives will be
looking at afterwards is how bad were
the results
relative to previous years to try and
get a gauge of how strongly
uh the public feel about uh this issue
and that could be another trigger point
as could be the wakefield by-election
that we've got coming up
at some point in the near future
just to conclude
in all seriousness what what do you
think of boris johnson as an individual
and as a prime minister i've read your
books i've got a rough idea
so
i i have a slightly schizophrenic view
of him i think he has some real
qualities i think if you take
ukraine he's handled that issue exactly
as i would have wanted my prime minister
to do it
but i'm afraid in other regards he falls
short of what i think we all have to
right to respect to expect in terms of
our prime minister and in this
particular story it's not just what he
did
at a time when all of the rest of us
were bringing here he passed laws
severely restricting all of our freedoms
and then didn't obey them himself but
it's the way he's behaved since those
allegations first came to like the way
the truth has been dragged out of him so
my my own view is very clear that they
can that we we
he's
he's failed if you like to pass the test
of acceptable behavior for a prime
minister and he needs to go
but ultimately this is a decision that
can serve to mps uh only they have got a
say in this until the next election
uh so
there are definitely some things he's
done that he can be proud of and i think
most people in this country would
support but in several critical regards
he falls short of what we have a right
to respect in terms of
prime minister